à donner à ce que la vie continue et ce
malgré la hausse des tensions avec le
voisin ukrainien tout proche et quoi de
mieux que le marché de la ville pour
prendre le pouls de la population
il ya ceux pour qui tout va bien mais
qui préfèrent éviter toute question sur
la politique
je suis de bonne humeur c'est le
printemps
tout est super aussi le travail c'est
génial merveilleux l'humeur est
excellente c'est le printemps
nous non pourquoi devrions-nous avoir
peur nous n'avons pas peur tout va bien
de quoi devrions-nous avoir peur
pour d'autres la peur existe mais au
final rien de nouveau les gens qui
vivent ici aujourd'hui sont eux qui ont
décidé de rester au plus fort des
combats partir n'est donc pas une option
nous vivons comme ça depuis presque huit
ans maintenant rien de nouveau ne se
passe pas une
certaine peur bien sûr car l'instinct de
conservation doit fonctionner s'il ne
fonctionne pas tout ira mal
d'un côté ça fait peur parce qu'on a des
enfants c'est pour eux qu'on s'inquiète
je ne m'inquiète pas pour moi même je
n'irai nulle part de toute façon
parmi mes connaissances tout le monde
reste ici tout le monde travaille encore
s'occupe de ses affaires et je ne veux
pas quitter ma ville natale on va rester
ici de toute façon dure et puis il ya
ceux qui en ont marre de toute cette
situation et qui se sont prisonniers
d'un contexte géopolitique qui les
dépasse on entend en fait tout ceci a
été créée artificiellement
nous en sommes conscients qu'est ce que
j'en pense que dois-je en pense et si je
suis isolé de tout et que je peux aller
nulle part nous vivons ici comme dans un
ghetto pardonnez moi l'expression
le marché la vie économique c'est une
chose mais qu'en est il de la vie
culturelle et elle impacté par les
événements allons voir dans ce théâtre
à l'opéra du donbass les répétitions se
succèdent le calendrier de
représentations cours sur les semaines à
venir on y prépare même un festival
international et ici comme ailleurs la
culture apporte sa pierre à l'édifice
il y à des russes doux et merveilleuses
ici ils ont besoin dead
je ne veux pas parler de grandes
politiques je parle de la politique que
je vois
je crois que la beauté sauvera le monde
tout d'abord la beauté de l'âme la
beauté de la romance russe la beauté de
ces gens ce qu'ils vivent ici et endure
toutes les difficultés de la vie et
espère un avenir meilleur
malgré les difficultés malgré la
lassitude de la population après toutes
ces années et bien la vie continue car
au final il n'y a pas d'autre choix